hi and welcome to the simply learn
YouTube channel in today's video we are
going to talk about Google ads we'll
discuss about what is Google ads how do
you use it what are the pros what are
the cons and I'll give you some tips and
tricks along the way now I am Mark kman
I'm your digital navigator for this
video and as usual if you like the video
just click the like button below and
subscribe to our Channel as well but
before we start let me share something
else with you so if you want to upskill
yourself in MA in and mastering digital
marketing skills maybe land your dream
job or grow your career then you must
explore simply learns cohort of various
digital marketing training programs they
offer a variety of certifications and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like um spj like Purdue and
even with meta now through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
experience in digital marketing skills
like search engine marketing like
strategies for paid campaigns
analytics return on investment and
evaluation of digital marketing and over
a dozen other digital marketing programs
but that's not all you will also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top tier product companies and
lecturers from top universities and
after completion of these courses
thousands of Learners of Simply learn
have transitioned into a digital
marketing role or moved on to a higher
paying job and a higher profile so if
you're passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure sure
to check the link on this slide and in
the comment below or in the uh the about
section below and uh find the digital
marketing program that fits you best and
that fits your experience and areas of
Interest so we hope to see you at one of
the simply learn
programs now let's move on let's get
started with our topic of today Google
ads and here you see what we will be
discussing after kicking off with a
short introduction on Google ads and its
history we're going to dive straight
into the deep with four demos that I
will be giving I will show you how to
register your business on the Google ads
platform I'll show you how to navigate
the Google ads dashboard then you'll be
learning how to create a campaign and
how to choose keywords and finally I'll
show you how to identify a target
audience and how to create an ad very
exciting topics to go through so let's
get started started let's talk about the
Google ads platform let me give you a
bit of a history of Google ads so born
out of the digital revolution in the
late 1990s early 2000s Google ads
formerly known by the way as Google adsw
traces it root back to early 2000s it
was launched by Google in fact in
October 2000 and it was a groundbreaking
response to the needs of online
businesses to get close closer to the
customers Google AdWords in those day
introduced a paradigm shift by allowing
advertisers to reach potential customers
through targeted online advertising so
over the years Google ads has undergone
massive Transformations adapting to the
changing dynamics of the online
landscape and additional opportunities
that arose from that from the
introduction of the quality score
algorithm to the evolution of campaign
types it consistently innovated so
advertisers could find more and do more
with more effective and efficient tools
so today Google ads is the standard as a
comprehensive and a sophisticated
platform serving a bridge between
advertisers and businesses and their
target audience and there are various
online channels that you can use like
Google search ads Google display Network
YouTube shopping ads and many other
opportunities that you have within the
Google ads platform so as we journey
through the Google ads demos that I'm
going to share with you let's not just
look at the functionalities but also
evolve uh understand how it has evolved
into an indispensable tool for
businesses who want to thrive in the
digital era so let's unlock the power of
Google ads together so you can position
I your brand in this Dynamic landscape
of online
advertising so what exactly is the
Google ads platform it is an advertising
platform where businesses can create and
manage digital advertising campaigns on
Google search YouTube the Display
Network and other owned by Google
properties so it is an online
advertising platform it connects
businesses with a global digital
audience now it works on a payperclick
Model where advertisers bit on keywords
related to their business yeah that is
for the Google search ads and it is one
of the most popular areas to advertise
and ads appear when users search for
Relevant keywords or on Google or its
partner sites so it also allows you to
Target very specific specific um sort of
interest groups or Affinity groups or
groups that have done certain um have
shown certain Behavior like visiting
your website and offering them like the
display advertising that they will see
on websites or YouTube ads that they are
visiting they can get specific campaign
types for specific goals like driving
traffic to your website generating leads
increasing brand
awareness the Google ads platform allows
targeting based on demographics on
interests on Geographic locations it
provides comprehensive tools and metrics
for campaign management and optimization
it also supports various ad formats like
text ads image ads video ads and display
ads and it finally empowers businesses
to reach their audience in an effective
manner to achieve their marketing
objectives so with that introduction
behind us let's kick off our demos so
navigating to Google ads is a must in
today's competitive Lal landscape yeah
the journey goes beyond the basics so
we're going to cover setup we're going
to look at campaign intricacies and
we're going to look at how do you create
Those ads so it'll be a practical demo
so it gives you the knowledge to refine
your online presence because digital
advertising is dynamic yeah it allows
you to get into a dynamic conversation
with your customers and it gives you
fantastic in insights to engage
effectively with your uh your customer
let's start by laying the groundwork and
how and look at how you register your
business on the Google ads
platform so let's kick off our journey
by registering your business on the
Google ads platform so simply go to
Google or the ads. goole.com log in with
your Google account and initiate a
process of connecting your business with
this extensive online audience but
before that let me quickly show you this
ads. goole.com page it gives you lots of
information and and knowledge about the
Google ads platform it can show you what
you can do with it how you can use it to
achieve your goals yeah you get you see
a voucher that you can get if you spend
$400 you get 400 pounds in add
credit so let's kick off your journey by
registering your business on the Google
ads platform so simply visit ads.
goole.com and you get to this website
which is kind of the entrance to Google
ads and on this website you find lots of
information about the Google ads
platform you even see here on the top
right that they give you a fure for 400
in the UK yeah where you can if you
spend 400 on uh on Advertising so you'll
see they do that across the world so you
should be able to get those uh those ad
vouches as well so it gives you lots of
suggestions on the goals that you can
achieve the power of Google advertising
for your business and it gives you some
case studies as well and what I really
like about the Google ads program that
you can actually get freeof charge
personalized support yep and by
scheduling a meet meeting with a Google
ads expert and I would highly um sort of
uh recommend you use that surfice
because they can really help you with
setting up your first Google ads
campaign
so let's go into this system we can
click Start now yeah or you can sign in
if you have an existing account so if
you click Start now it'll probably
immediately log in to my existing
account but what it will do it will
actually give you an overview of the
Google ads accounts that you already
have yeah or you can create a new Google
ads account
so this step forms the backbone for your
online identity and it gets you with an
an seamless integration between your
business and the Google ads um
environment as it were so very practical
steps to get you started on the Google
ads platform effectively so let's go on
to create a new Google ads
account so create a new
account and here it goes into the
process of creating a new Google ads
account so you need to add business
information you can then go straight
into creating your ad and set up your
budget now you can case go straight into
your first campaign and in the process
you will actually fill in your data to
sign up but what I advise you do here is
to skip the campaign creation that
you're not ready and then you will go in
a proper setup for your Google
ads so there's different elements that
you can do here so you give your billing
country you give your time zone your
currency if you want personalized
campaign guidance I would certainly
advise you take that as I mentioned
earlier yeah you fill that data in and
then you click submit and then yes to
continue I'll I'll select no for now so
click submit and then you're basically
all done and then uh The Next Step
what's going to happen is actually you
need to go through the verification
process now a few more steps here the
details are very important if you go
through the entire process like your
business name your physical location
your contact information it's not about
get the data but is about crafting your
digital presence yeah so it goes beyond
checkboxes make sure that you add every
step yeah that you fill in every step in
the
process okay so the next step is that
you will go through the verification
process when you've done that process it
is very important that you are going to
verify your account so how do you verify
your account you go back to your main
Google ads dashboard and I will explain
this dashboard a little later and you
click here on the billing and here you
see Advertiser
verification yes so here is where you go
into
verification
to make sure that Google recognizes your
account and understands that you are the
actual business owner of this account so
that gives you an extra level of
security and integrity on your Google
ads account and once you verify it yes
so B Google has then reviewed your
business details and you can ensure your
accuracy but it can also gives you a
good foundation for this for your
advertising experience so it's more than
Security checks it's about making sure
that your data is is correct and you
have a solid basis to start your journey
in the Google
advertising entering the ads dashboard
so here we are on the Google ads
dashboard so let's start the so let's
start the second part of our Google ads
demo here is the ads dashboard it's like
stepping into the command center of your
digital advertising operations this
centralized Hub offers a panoramic view
of your campaigns the performance
metrics and a toolkit for efficient ad
creation and AD management it's the Nerf
Center as we say where you have a
comprehensive overview and control of
your entire advertising landscape think
of it as your strategic headquarters it
gives you the insights and the tools
needed to navigate the entire Google ads
advertising platform so what it gives
you it gives you tabs for campaigns for
goals for tools for billing to admin to
the admin of your account and it also
gives you the overview recommendations
on how to and where to improve your ads
it gives you you insights and reports it
gives you an overview of your campaigns
your advertising assets your audiences
your keywords and the change history and
it is um each step as it were serves as
a gateway to specific functionalities
for monitoring and optimizing your
advertising activities so getting
experienced in using this dashboard is
key for effective campaign management
yes so you really need to start
practicing this it is not complicated
you don't need to use every
functionality but in these demos I will
show you the path you need to take to go
through the um the different menu
settings so the overview gives you a
deeper insight into your campaigns and
your campaign metrics yeah it gives you
the number of clicks you had on your
campaign it gives you the number of
Impressions the average cost per click
how much you've spent on a campaign you
can download a report you can set the
dates these are very important metrics
that can help you in improving your
campaigns here you see your recently
created campaigns yeah and lots of other
details that you are get vital signs of
your campaigns guiding you to make
informed DEC decisions for your campaign
progress and again it's very important
that you understand these metrics so it
makes it helps you to make sure that
your advertising efforts are not just
active but that they are effectively
aligned with your overall business
goals okay now a very important part is
the toolbox that you get in here yeah so
in the toolbox
you get information to plan your
campaigns like a Keyword Planner a
performance planner a reach planner
there is your shared Library where you
get access to your audience manager your
exclusion lists your brand list yeah the
content the Google tag um that you can
get here we'll talk about that later
troubleshooting bulk actions more info
about budgets and biding so a lot of e
extra additional aspects you can get
here in your uh your toolbox that you
will definitely need in executing your
campaign and uh a number of these tools
we will discuss in our demo it's very
important that you master the tools that
you have here because they will make the
execution of your campaigns and planning
them a lot easier if you use these tools
so each tool serves a unique purpose in
enhancing the effectiveness of your um
your campaigns so let's start the second
part of our Google ads demo here is the
ads dashboard it's like stepping into
the command center of your digital
advertising operations this centralized
Hub offers a panoramic view of your
campaigns the performance metrics and a
toolkit for efficient ad creation and AD
management it's the Nerf Center as we
say where you have a comprehensive
overview and control of your entire
advertising landscape think of it as
your strategic headquarters it gives you
the insights and the tools needed to
navigate the entire Google ads
advertising platform so what it gives
you it gives you tabs for campaigns for
goals for tools for billing to admin to
the admin of your account and it also
gives you the overview recommendations
on how to and where to improve your ads
it gives you insights and reports it
gives you an overview of your campaigns
your advertising assets your audiences
your keywords and the change history and
it is um each step as it were serves as
a gateway to specific functionalities
for monitoring and optimizing your
advertising activities so getting
experienced in using this dashboard is
key for Effective campaign management
yes so you really need to start
practicing this it is not complicated
you don't need to use every
functionality but in these demos I will
show you the path you need to take to go
through the um the different menu
settings so the over view gives you a
deeper insight into your campaigns and
your campaign metrics yeah it gives you
the number of clicks you had on your
campaign it gives you the number of
Impressions the average cost per click
how much you've spent on a campaign you
can download the report you can set the
dates these are very important metrics
that can help you in improving your
campaigns here you see your recently
created campaigns yeah and lots of other
details that you are get vital signs of
your campaigns guiding you to make
informed decisions for your campaign
progress and again it's very important
that you understand these metrics so it
makes it helps you to make sure that
your advertising efforts are not just
active but that they are effectively
aligned with your overall business goals
okay now a very important part is the
toolbox that you get in here yeah so in
the toolbox you get information to plan
your campaigns like a Keyword Planner a
performance planner a reach planner
there is your shared Library where you
get access to your audience manager your
exclusion list your brand list yeah the
content the Google tag um that you can
can get here we'll talk about that later
troubleshooting bulk actions more info
about budgets and bidding so a lot of e
extra additional aspects you can get
here in your uh your toolbox that you
will definitely need in executing your
campaign and uh a number of these tools
we will discuss in our demo it's very
important that you master the tools that
you have here because they will make the
execution of your campaigns and planning
them a lot easier if you use these tools
in setting up your campaign it's also
very important to look at the structure
of your Google ads and the standard
structure of a Google ads campaign is to
in it's three folds there is the
campaign level there is the ad group and
within the ad group sits the um sit the
ads and and the ads they inherit the
setting of the ad group and the ad group
they inherit the setting of The
campaigns on campaign level you talk
about the objectives of your campaign
you look at the um the the bidding
strategy that you have for your campaign
in the the price that you the budget
that you want to assign in the ad groups
you can look at your keywords and you
can specify your ads as well so very
important that you think about that
structure and that will re really help
you into organizing your campaign in a
structured
manner okay having gone through this
dashboard now let's jump into the Google
ads Basics and create a campaign and
picking the right keywords so to create
a campaign you just go to the campaigns
Tab and you click here the plus to start
or I can click here on the campaign step
I'm getting an overview of my campaign
aigns and um but in this case I just
click on the campaign tab on the plus
button and that will take me to the sort
of the starting screen of my um Google
ad setup so I can decide my campaign
goal I can set a budget and I can pick a
bidding strategy so this is the
beginning of your ad game here you state
what you want do you want more clicks do
you want leads do you want brand
awareness how much do you want to spend
what is your bidding strategy do you
want to set it or do you want Google to
handle it yeah do you want more clicks
more
conversions and when you start this
process you're on the way to create your
first ads plan
so here you
see
the different types
of campaign objectives that you can
select and each objective will kind of
pre-select the digital narrative within
Google ads so they serve different
purposes whether it is driving sales or
driving website traffic um or whether it
is capturing leads whether it is
promoting your app whether it is a local
store visit whether it is sales or a
product and brand consideration or you
can also decide to create a campaign
without selecting any of these and that
is for the more experienced people who
can who know exactly what to specify but
if you click one of these then Google
will automatically prepopulate kind of
the settings for you in the uh in the
Google ads screen that will follow so
aligning these types with your goals is
very important and they ensure that you
get a very impactful digital marketing
approach to your customers so let's
click on one of them yes so let's click
for instance on the uh we want website
traffic so here you see what type of
conversions that you want yes so that
could be page views that could submit
lead forms it could subscribe so you can
specify these conversions and you just
click here you click on continue and
here you select the campaign sort of
type that you want to select want to to
to run do you want a search campaign do
you want a display campaign do you want
Google to sort of Select it for you yeah
do you want a shopping campaign a video
campaign or do you want a demand J then
where you run ads on Youtube Gmail and
various other channels so let's say
we're going to create a um let's start
with a search campaign yeah so you put
in your website your website address
which in my case would be this website
you're going to give your campaign a
name and you click continue I'm going to
start a new campaign and here it's very
important that you specify the bidding
strategy that you set as you know Google
ADS works with an auction system you put
in a bid for when what you will pay uh
when people click on your ad and then
Google in the auction when people have
actually put in one of your keywords
Google will then use different methods
for making sure that the um the the best
bit in combination of various other
factors wins as it were and shows up at
the top of the uh the advertising
listings on Google ads now the the
highest bidder doesn't necessarily be at
automatically be at the the number one
spot there is also a quality score of
your ad that is impacting whether or not
you would show at the top so your
financial uh core rest on the budget and
the bidding strategy so determine your
daily budget yeah align it with your
advertising
objectives and uh it's very
important how you want to set this do
you want to run it for conversions do
you want to run it for clicks yep so you
can set a maximum cost per click or you
can let Google set that automatically
for you yep and and when you're happy
with how you set it you click next and
then you specify where you want to show
your
ads yep so here you see you can specify
the for the Google search campaign you
can specify the search Network you can
also show search ads on the Display
Network you can look at the network the
locations the languages you can specify
specific audiences or you can also do
some keyword matching for your search
campaigns there's various location
options they work very powerful yeah so
you can spe specify by language you can
select audience segments so for instance
I would just do an advertisement on a
specific
sector so I can say give me just people
that are interested in
travel and they will then be added to uh
they will then be targeted with your
your
ads yep and then here you're going to
specify your uh the type of keyword
match that you want
so uh so that is very important and as
you can see in the Google search ads the
keywords are very important but I'll
come back to that in a minute what I
first want to do is go through the more
settings where you will sort of open up
additional functionality that will make
you use um give you a more advanced use
of the Google ads like how do you want
to rotate your ads is there a started an
end dat for your campaign do you have a
specific ad schedule do you have
campaign URL options that is where you
want to um to track your campaigns or
Are there specific brand and
restrictions that you do not want to
associate with your ads and the
placement of your ads so particularly on
the ad schedule my recommendation would
be to select all day when you start your
ads let's Google decide what is the best
timings for your ads that gives the best
response what you will see when you set
up your ads that you set up multiple ads
and Google will mix and match the ads
and will'll select the best combination
of the ads that will give you the best
performance and we'll also select the
best timings so the first couple of days
that your advertising campaign is
running Google will be in what we say
learning mode and it will do all the
tests it will run the various options of
your ads and it will sort of slowly
calibrate your ad campaign to the best
format the best settings and the best
structure so this type of
control yeah is not about just Reaching
Your Right audience but it also does it
at the most opportune moments the best
times so it maximizes the effectiveness
of your uh your ads so very important
part of this is your keywords as I just
mentioned so for search campaigns here
is where you can specify your keywords
so what you can do you can get
suggestions from Google by entering your
website address and then Google will and
will sort of select the best keywords
for you and you can use those for your
search ads which means that every time
somebody types in any of these keywords
your ad will show to
the to those people depending on your
bidding strategy or you can add your own
keywords based on your keyword research
and the tool that I showed you earlier
the Google Keyword Planner is a
fantastic tool that can help you in
building those um those those keyword
lists for you now I'm not going to go
into the details here of keyword uh
research that may be the topic for a
future uh campaign so it's very
important that you align your keywords
with your business and that the keywords
resonate with your target audience and
make sure that you use the key Google
Keyword Planner to find the right
keywords or any other tools that uh that
are available in the market the keyword
is fundamental for your search campaign
it's not about what you say in your ad
but it is also how do those keywords
resonate with you your
audience good that concludes the basic
setup of your ads on a campaign level
and on an ad group
level we're now going to look at our
next demo where we're going to look at
targeting and also where we're going to
look at how to create an
ad so as we shift Focus the spotlight
turns now to defining and refining your
target
audience and particularly this will be
important when you set up a display
campaign and when you go into the
campaign settings for the display and
you follow the menu down here you get to
the targeting option and that is the
first place where you can specify your
the which people you target
with your display ads so this is where
you can identify demographics interests
and behaviors that resonate with your
brand so this ensures if you set that
that your ads are displayed to those
people that are most likely to engage
with your Brands so navigating through
this audience setting is not about
casting a wiet it is about Precision
about reaching the right people at the
right time
so let's click on the targeting and you
see here that you hone in on various
areas you can hone in on audience
segments demographics keywords topics
and placement and here while you're
going through these targeting options
you can keep track of your um estimated
number of Impressions and your estimated
performance for your ads so exploring
this array of audio targeting options
audience targeting options is about
tailoring your message to different
personalities different audiences so
look at audience
segments that is where you can select
audiences who are particularly
interested in travel or lifestyle and
hobbies and there is literally hundreds
of segments that people can um can
select yeah you can search for any
segment you can let's say here let's do
um train
Enthusiast just taking a random topic
yeah let's see what comes up and here is
train
information train hobby traveling by
train um yeah so everything to do with
trains that you can pick here you can
even probably take miniature trains so
you can Target those people
very specifically that ensures that your
ad is not visible but also relevant to
specific segments of your target
audience so that is through the audience
segments and again if you pick one so
say um train information then here you
see how your weekly estimates are um are
changing yeah so you can SC by selecting
you put them in your Target and then you
see how your um advertising campaign is
likely to perform so let's stay away
from the train let's go to um Adventure
travel for instance and now you get all
those people that are interested in
adventure
vacations activity
holidays Wildlife trips Etc and again
you see how your performance is changing
so that is the audience segments we then
going to go to the next level that is
demographics we're targeting male let's
say um
between 25 and 44 years with a slightly
higher higher household income let's say
the top um 21 so we're going for the the
top uh tier and again your estimates are
being
adjusted and then you can go to the next
one you can add targeting so you can
Target keywords so this is for instance
I am targeting those people that have a
specific interest in Kilimanjaro for
instance and um
Kilimanjaro yep and I can add that as a
keyword if I want and morocc
and you see how my weekly estimates are
becoming more and more specific I can
add keyword ideas through from my
website as well so let's say that is
done and then we can go to the the
final uh targeting which was by topics
yeah or you can even Target by
placements so if we want Adventure
magazines
yeah so Adventure magazines you can then
select those magazines or those online
Publications where your ads will show so
you can ask by default ask Google to
select this for you but if you're very
experienced in your industry you know
specific magazines where you want to
place your ad then very likely you will
find them in the list here it takes a
little while to go through this list of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of online Publications but then you can
really Target very specific by magazine
while it is doing this let's go to the
optimized targeting which is on which
means Google will actually help you get
more viewable Impressions yeah find
people beyond your targeting signals so
that is what Google will help you to
fine-tune your um uh your targeting and
um give you even better results for your
campaign yes so we targeted the
adventure Channel Adventure magazine so
here are 253 websites there are YouTube
channels that you can Target YouTube
videos apps and app categories where
your ad can show so this is a very good
section where you can make your ads
reach the right people so that is one
area where you can
feature um where you can be very
specific in the targeting of your ad
that is within the display campaign
settings you can also Target People
based on
behavior and one very important behavior
is um what they have done on your
website in the
past yeah and that is what we're going
to look at next as part of this audience
segmentation and audience targeting
we're going to look at how can I
leverage activities from people behavior
of people for instance visiting my
website or buying a product how can I
how can I capitalize on those um on
those people and maybe put them in a
separate audience that I can then Target
with my ads this is what we call
retargeting and I can Target people with
an ad once they visited my website for a
particular product P page for instance
and I'm sure you've experienced that
yourself that you were visiting an ad
and that you that you were visiting a
product on a website and then you put a
product in the basket but you decide not
to buy that product and then the next
time you go on Facebook or on YouTube
you actually see a product for that ad
so that is the next section that we will
be looking
at a new feature in Google ads are
conversion
goals conversion goals help you organize
your conversion actions so that you can
more move more easily towards achieving
your advertising objectives so actions
that you want your customers to take or
conversion actions are grouped together
based on Rel related categories to form
these conversion goals so how do you get
there you go here to goals you click on
conversions and here you have a summary
of your conversion goals for example the
purchase conversion or the Subscribe
conversion goal would automatically
contain all conversion actions from
people to subscribe to a particular form
and this simplifies your conversion
management and it improves your campaign
performance so very powerful new aspect
within Google ads to manage your
conversions in one central place so how
do you set a aay conversion you set it
up here in the new conversion
action so you can set up a conversion
action for your website for your apps or
for phone calls or you can import data
from Google or from Salesforce or other
um tools but the most important one
again is getting conversion tracking
setup for your website so when you click
on that you can then put in your website
domain you can click
scan and it will then scan the website
if it's already set up to measure
conversions which basically means have
you already set up conversion tags on
your
website so Google ads can track those
web pages so you can it has been set up
so you can actually create specific
conversion actions you can do that from
website events you can also create
conversion actions manually by using
specific code so if you use transaction
specific values transaction ideas yeah
so then you can use this option but the
easiest one is to use the create
conversion action from website event so
you can actually accept suggestion for
setting up a conversion goal you can
also add a conversion goal so you can
select the category for
instance um a subscribe the event type
could be a page load on this website and
then you just click add
the URL is required for that would be
the about us yeah and then I click add
and then the the code has been the
conversion goal has been created I click
save and
continue and then it sets up this
conversion
action where of course I need to make
sure I set it up properly with a Google
tag through Google tag manager now this
section is not about teaching you how to
use Google tag manager we have a
separate video for that but I just want
to make you aware of the process of how
to do that you can also email the
instructions to your Web Master yep so
let's say if we want to email the
instruction then we'll just put in the
email address and then it's uh sent or
you can also set it up yourself and then
what you do do is you get a piece of
code where you that you basically need
to copy and that you need to paste in
the Google tag manager so you can use
the Google tag manager that's where you
use this particular piece of code you
can also install manually and here is
the piece of code that you need to
install on every page of the
website so then Google can see that that
is a tag for those specifical specific
conversion goals that um Google then can
then start
tracking good you can test the
installation as well but I'll just want
to make you aware where you go to set
that
up okay so those are the conversion
goals in
Google the last topic of this
demo the last topic of this demo is ADD
placements and the network to add
networks and the actual creation of ads
this is very important it is like
choosing the stage for your performance
and exploring the various options
including the Google search Network the
Display Network and YouTube is vital to
align your uh your ads with your
advertising of network your advertising
objectives so the
different ad options that you have they
start with the Google search Network the
Google search Network places your ads in
search engine results that gives you
visibility for your ads when users
actively search for related content the
next area is the Display Network that
showcases your ad across a multitude of
websites and apps thereby having a big
reach of your uh your ads YouTube as a
video platform offers a very extensive
ad ad vertising platform with lots of
advertising opportunities and different
um different versions of ads and
tailoring your approach to each
platform will amplify the effectiveness
of your ad strategy to make sure that
you get maximum impact on your ads now
let's go to the fun part of Google ads
and that is the actual creation of your
ads so we'll head to over to the ads we
go to the campaigns click a campaign
here is the campaign we're going to
first create a search ads which is let's
say for website
traffic we go to continue and here is
the search ad that we're going to create
We'll add our
website and we'll click
continue and we'll start a new campaign
and where we're going to is the keywords
and the ads so we have already set up
the keywords we're going now straight to
the actual ads and this is a very
important section where you are able to
set up your Google search ads they are
based on um
the a combination of headlines up to 15
and
descriptions up to
four and a number of extensions like
sight links or call outs and different
other
extensions okay you can set that all up
and then Google will mix and Ma match
those different elements of your ads to
come up with the ad with the best
performance and what's really nice here
is they show you a preview of what the
ad will look like with the different
headlines and the different
descriptions and here you see your
campaign optimization score with the
weekly estimates of how many conversions
and how many what your weekly cost is
here you see your add strength and here
you see at the moment it is poor because
I need to make the description more more
unique so you can get ideas and you'll
see that this area will will become more
and more advanced and more and more
driven by artificial intelligence in the
future yeah to make sure that you get
the best ads possible for your
market so again this is a short demo I'm
not going to go into every little detail
yeah but this is where you create your
search ads so that is the first
area the second area where you create
your ads is of course for the display
campaigns so if I go back to Google
ads and I am going to create a new
campaign but now I'm going to create a
brand awareness campaign for display ads
again here I say ratar
russia.com I click continue I'm going to
go start
new and here I can of course we've been
through all these settings remember the
campaign settings the budget and the
bidding and the targeting and here we go
to the
ads and here you can
specify the URL your business name you
can add up to 15 images so where you
upload an image let's say we're going to
use the image of this room and you see
here in different formats and we're
going to add this images as well so
we're going to click save
and then you can add a text you could
even add a video you can add a headline
and here you will see what the ad will
looks look
like now make sure that you have
switched off your ad blocker if you have
set up an ad blocker and because when
you have an ad blocker then this the the
the preview of the ad will not show so
so I need to add the final URL I need to
add the https for
this yep so here is the final URL with
the business name and now in a bit the
ad should show up we should have the
business name two images One headline so
we'll add um welcome to riat
Russia and a
description book your adventure enture
holiday
now okay and then here you see how the
ad would look
like very simple very straightforward
but it is all about of course the
quality of the images the headlines that
you're using the description that you're
using but at least this gives you an
idea of what an ad looks like and how
you would create that within the display
um add
category so here is a few
tips yes so add copy is very important
yeah relevant visuals and formulate
clear call to actions they are the
fundamental elements of your in of your
ads compelling ad copy is about Clarity
and enticement and about having a
concise message and be different so the
integration of the relevant visuals that
enhances the overall appeal now calls to
action I can't emphasize enough and the
uh they guide users on the desired next
steps and that will drive
conversions so keep that in mind and
this all comes back to clearly defining
your objectives
so outline your advertising goals
whether it's increasing website traffic
gener ating leads or boosting sales
welldefined objectives will guide your
entire ads
strategy also do very thorough keyword
research yeah comprehend do a
comprehensive keyword research to
identify the relevant terms for your
business and try to familiarize yourself
with the tools like Google Keyword
Planner so you can discover the high
performance key uh keyword words also
think about your ad copy develop
compelling ad copy that speaks directly
to your target audience use your unique
selling points include relevant keywords
create a craw strong to call a strong
call to action landing pages very
important ensure that your landing pages
yeah that your adds direct the users to
optimized and seamless um and seamless
experience on your landing page content
on your landing page should be aligned
with your ad and the page should be
userfriendly and have a very clear call
to action in the search ad make sure
that you use ad extensions take
advantage of those ad expansions provide
additional information in your ads and
increase ad visibility so extension
links like site links call outs
structured Snippets they enhance your ad
providing users with more reasons to
click to conclude remember yeah that
Google ads isn't just a tool it is not
just a presence it is a dynamic
connection with a fast online audience
and they say through Google ads you can
reach around 90 plus% of the internet
audience and by crafting well organized
campaigns and using the um library of
tools in the ads dashboard that will be
the perfect combination for
Success think about the keywords it's
not just an afterthought it is the the
glue that holds your campaigns together
and understanding these intricacies of
Google ads that can become your
competitive difference in launching your
ad campaign so that basically concludes
this uh this video we've covered the
essentials on Google ads from campaign
initiation to ad Creation with an
emphasis on
practicality yeah now armed with this
knowledge you are better positioned to
orchestrate your own effective ad
campaigns and make sure that you get the
conversions that you that you want so
that concludes it for today thanks for
joining this exploration as you venture
in this new world of Google ads you
campaigns make sure they are strategic
your keywords be impactful and your
Dynamic your digital presence be dynamic
so I wish you the best of luck in your
advertising behaviors remember if you
like this video click the like button
below and subscribe to our um our
Network so you get access to other
videos
that we will be publishing in the near
future so thanks for your time and I'll
see you at the next video staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTu
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click
here